merci la parole est à monsieur yves
albarello merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
nous avons pris connaissance récemment
du rapport de la cour des comptes et de
ses recommandations sur l'évolution des
relations entre l'état et les buralistes
ce rapport appellent à revoir de fond en
comble le modèle de distribution du
tabac provoquant par là même une forte
inquiétude chez les buralistes qui reste
comme vous le savez profondément attaché
au statut de préposés de
l'administration et aux responsabilités
qui en découlent
la cour des comptes semble aussi
remettre en cause par ces
recommandations le protocole d'accord
signé le 15 novembre entre le secrétaire
d'état au budget et la confédération
dont les buralistes attendent avec
impatience la mise en application
intégrale or ce protocole d'accord cible
les aides attribuées aux buralistes et
vise à les rendre plus efficace comme le
souhaite la cour cet accord prévoit
aussi une subvention spécifique
répondant à l'objectif de modernisation
que la cour des comptes recommande
fortement et que le réseau attend
impatiemment
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
est double pouvez vous confirmer devant
la représentation nationale qu'il n'est
pas dans les intentions de votre
gouvernement de revenir sur le protocole
d'accord du 15 novembre
ma deuxième question pouvez-vous
confirmer ainsi qu'il n'est pas envisagé
de modifier les équilibres des relations
entre l'administration et le réseau des
buralistes dont l'existence même apporte
à l'état les meilleures garanties
possibles pour la distribution
réglementé d'un produit aussi sensible
que le tabac je vous remercie
merci la parole et à monsieur christian
eckert secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget et des comptes publics
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés chez le député
albarello c'est bizarre tu
l'interprétation que qui peut être fait
différemment sur vauban des conclusions
de la cour des comptes mais ça je le
laisse à votre appréciation votre ma
réponse sera double premièrement
est ce que l'état à l'intention de
remettre en cause le protocole que j'ai
signé avec le président montredon il ya
quelques mois bien sûr que non bien sûr
que non vous l'avez dit vous-même ce
protocole bien avant le rapport de la
cour des comptes
grâce à une relation constructive que
nous avons pu avoir à par avance répondu
aux critiques de la cour en ciblant
mieux les aides sur les secteurs en
difficulté en insistant sur la
nécessaire modernisation des
installations un accompagnement en
accompagnant pardon les mutations
nécessaires dans cette profession
les décrets je fais une confidence j'ai
vu le président marron dont lundi soir
avons encore travaillé un tout petit peu
sur quelques détails sur les décrets
d'application qui vont sortir dans les
tout prochains jours sur votre deuxième
question à savoir quelle est la relation
avec les buralistes je viens de vous le
dire président moreau dont je les ai
rencontrés lundi soir
nous avons évoqué des questions
relatives à leur relation avec la
française des jeux n'a pas échappé que
la française des jeux et a pour
actionnaire majoritaire l'état
là encore devront travailler sur
l'implantation des nouvelles des
nouveaux réseaux de distribution d'un
française des jeux et je fais une
deuxième confidence j'ai eu france
stéphane pallez à midi au téléphone et
rencontre cet après midi le président de
la confédération des buralistes
donc oui les relations sont
constructives elles sont exigeantes sur
des sujets délicats
je crois que tout le monde reconnaît que
le réseau évolué favorablement